Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Surfshark,
más sobre esto en un momento.
Solemos pensar que el mundo está configurado
en torno a un grupito de enormes potencias
que son las que manejan los hilos de todo.
Estados Unidos, China, puede que hasta hace
poco Rusia, quizás en el futuro la India…
Pero… ¿y si os dijera que hay países mucho
más pequeños y, aparentemente, inofensivos
que de repente consiguen una gigantesca influencia
a escala global?
¿Y si os hablásemos de países que ni son
ni los más ricos del mundo, ni tienen porqué
tener armas nucleares, grandes ejércitos
o mucha población, y que a pesar de todo
han conseguido hacerse un hueco en el tablero
geopolítico internacional?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo
os vamos a poner varios ejemplos que lo están
logrando.
Pero antes no estaría de más poner sobre
la mesa la clave última de su renovada influencia:
hablamos del conocido como poder blando.
Y, ojo, que esto puede llegar a ser mucho
más importante de lo que te puedas imaginar.
(Podríamos decir que ese tipo de estrategia
o poder consiste en ser capaces de impactar,
influir y persuadir a personas de todo el
mundo para cumplir con unos determinados objetivos.
Para ello se utilizan elementos como la cultura,
los valores, la innovación, el deporte, la
diplomacia o, incluso, la filantropia.
Es el concepto opuesto al poder duro o hard
power, que es el que se ejerce a través de
la coerción, el uso de la fuerza o las amenazas
y chantajes económicos.
Un tipo de poder en el que, lógicamente,
las grandes potencias tienen muchas ventajas.
Es decir, sintetizando que mientras que el
poder duro depende de la fuerza, el poder
blando lo hace de la persuasión y la atracción.)
A ver, sobre la in fluencia y el peso militar
ya os hemos hablado en un montón de vídeos.
Es un tema recurrente en VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, de lo que nunca antes os habíamos
hablado es de cómo cualquier país puede
multiplicar su relevancia y su influencia
internacional recurriendo a la persuasión.
Lo que, además, puede resultar todo un chute
de energía para sus empresas y productos.
Y, podéis creerme, no estamos bromeando.
Son muchos los países que están ya desarrollando
esta línea de trabajo.
Así que, sin más preámbulo…¿Os parece
que descubramos qué países están siendo
capaces de competir de tú a tú con las grandes
potencias?
¿Cómo lo están consiguiendo exactamente?
Pues queridos amigos, vamos a ir viendo cada
arista de este nuevo enfoque.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Lo vamos a ir viendo con ejemplos concretos.
Arranquemos.
[Pero antes, dejadme haceros una pregunta:
¿eres consciente de todo lo que te estás
perdiendo por no usar Surfshark?
Lo primero y quizás más importante para
muchos de nosotros: la protección de navegar
de forma segura.
Surfshark cifra tu actividad en internet de
modo que nadie pueda rastrear ni robar tus
datos; Bloquea anuncios y malware con CleanWeb;
y protege tus cuentas de correo electrónico
con Surfshark Alert, recibiendo una notificación
cuando se filtre tu información personal.
Y eso no es todo.
Surfshark es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de 100 países distintos,
lo que significa que puedes abrir a golpe
de click un nuevo mundo de contenidos restringidos
según tu ubicación.
Además, con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
TODOS los dispositivos que quieras sin límite:
tu teléfono, tablet, la SmartTV, el portátil.
Pero lo mejor de todo viene ahora: por ser
parte de la comunidad VisualPolitik podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento y 3 meses
gratis usando el código “POLITIK”.]
Dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!
T1(EL SURGIMIENTO DEL ‘K-POWER’)
Uno de los países que más ha aumentado su
influencia internacional y que más ha mejorado
su imagen exterior durante los últimos tiempos
es…
Sí, efectivamente, Corea del Sur.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya hemos hablado de
este país en varios vídeos.
Os hemos hablado de temas políticos, económicos,
militares y sociales pero sobre lo que nunca
habíamos hablado es de cómo este país se
ha convertido a toda velocidad en uno de los
países más populares del mundo..
Seguro que todos conocéis el KPOP o las series
coreanas que han arrasado en Netflix, como,
por ejemplo, El Juego del Calamar.
Pero mucho antes de todo eso, antes de que
el Gangnam Style se convirtiera en el video
más visto de YouTube, de que grupos como
BTS o Black Pink conquistaran el mundo, o
de que la película Parásitos ganara cuatro
Oscar, la llamada “ola coreana” ya había
conquistado el continente asiático.
Puede, incluso, que alguno de vosotros a raíz
de todo este tema os estáis animando a probar
la comida coreana….
Una comida que se está haciendo cada vez
más popular.
Cine, música, cultura y gastronomía…
Puede parecernos poca cosa, pero, ¿no resulta
sorprendente que un país como este esté
teniendo semejante impacto mundial?
¿Habéis pensado, por ejemplo, alguna vez
en los coches que aparecen sistemáticamente
en las series coreanas?
Si no lo habéis hecho, fijaos, pero casi
siempre son o Hyundai, o Génesis o Kia.
Casi que podríamos hablar de un mega anuncio
para una de las industrias más importantes
de este país.Y, por supuesto no hablamos
solo de los coches.
Pero esta es tan solo una de las aristas que
tiene esta enorme exposición mundial.
Una visibilidad que en el caso de Corea del
Sur no ha llegado caída del cielo.
Todo lo contrario.
Podríamos llegar a decir que ha formado parte
de una estrategia de Estado desde hace varias
décadas.
(Muchos expertos consideran que el apoyo del
gobierno fue clave en el Hallyu [PRON: Jaliu],
la ola coreana de contenidos culturales surgida
en los años 90,.
Por ejemplo en 1998, el entonces presidente
Kim Dae Jung [PRON: Kim Dé Tsong] anunció
el primer plan de apoyo a la industria Hallyu.
El objetivo era impulsar la industria cultural
para convertirla en un gran escaparate del
país.
Y no fueron solo palabras.
En apenas 3 años el presupuesto público
destinado a la industria cultural se triplicó.
El éxito cosechado fue tan rotundo que el
siguiente gobierno, el de Roh Moo Hyun [PRON:
No Mu Hyon], continuó aumentando las inversiones
en la industria cultural.
De hecho, también se establecieron varias
leyes así como agencias gubernamentales destinadas
exclusivamente a la promoción de estos contenidos
culturales dentro y fuera del país.)
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensando…
Si fuera tan fácil como poner dinero sobre
la mesa, muchos países podrían hacer lo
mismo, ¿no os parece?
Pues, lo cierto es que en este caso, la clave
del éxito de la ola coreana no fue realmente
la contribución económica del gobierno,
sino sobre todo que el proceso estuvo totalmente
dirigido y gestionado por empresas y productoras
privadas enfocadas a la obtención de beneficios.
Digamos que en este caso el gobierno jugó
un papel similar al que tuvo el estado de
Israel en la promoción de las empresas tecnológicas,
tal y como ya os contamos recientemente en
VisualEconomik.
Es decir, puso dinero para apoyar a la industria,
pero le dio está todo el control…
Con una premisa, además, muy clara: tenían
que ser competitivas por sí mismas.
Es decir, tenían que ganar todo el dinero
que les fuera posible.
Y así, poco a poco el estado fue alimentando
un sector que les podría reportar mucha visibilidad
internacional.
Fijaos.
(“La cultura ha surgido como un elemento
indispensable de la competitividad de una
nación y un recurso económico que produce
valor añadido.
Para mantenerse al día con este entorno global
cambiante, Corea ha adoptado la diplomacia
cultural como un nuevo pilar de la estructura
diplomática del país.”
- Libro Blanco de Diplomacia de Corea del
Sur, año 2010)
Y creedme cuando os digo que se lo toman bastante
en serio.
Por ejemplo, el Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores
surcoreano realiza investigaciones sobre el
impacto del Hallyu en cada país, y en función
de los resultados promueve actividades de
fans y eventos culturales.
Otro ejemplo es que el gobierno patrocina
del 20 al 30 por ciento de un enorme fondo
de inversión de 1.000 millones de dólares
destinado a hacer crecer y a exportar la cultura
pop coreana.
Algo que como veis no ha surgido por casualidad.
(Uno de los objetivos de esta fuerte apuesta
ha sido el de mejorar la imagen internacional
de Corea del Sur.
Un país que desde su fundación en 1948 ha
pasado por una devastadora guerra y por una
sucesión de dictaduras militares hasta los
años 90.
Dictaduras que, obviamente, violaban consistentemente
los derechos humanos y que contribuyeron a
que la imagen del país en el exterior fuera
bastante negativa.
Durante mucho tiempo se vio a Corea como una
especie de megafábrica dirigida por sátrapas
y enormes grupos empresariales de corte familiar
que eran apoyados por políticos corruptos.
Como podréis imaginar, no era la mejor carta
de presentación.)
Así que con la llegada de la democracia al
conocido como país de la mañana tranquila,
los políticos no solo tuvieron que ponerse
manos a la obra para limpiar las instituciones
también tuvieron que empeñarse a fondo para
mejorar la imagen del país dentro y fuera
de sus fronteras.
Y ya lo veis…
¡Dicho y hecho!
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Hay un par de datos que nos pueden servir
para entender el enorme éxito que han tenido.
Por ejemplo, según la Organización Mundial
del Turismo, entre 1995 y 2019, que es el
último dato pre-pandemia, el número de turistas
que recibió Corea del Sur creció un 367
por ciento, pasando de unos 3,75 millones
a casi 18.
De esta forma el turismo se está convirtiendo
en una enorme fuente de ingresos completamente
nueva.
(Otro dato que demuestra la influencia que
ha tenido esta apuesta cultural lo tenemos
con el número de personas que de repente
deciden estudiar su idioma.
Podemos fijarnos, por ejemplo, en el número
de estudiantes que cada año se apuntan a
los exámenes oficiales.
Pues bien, ojo con este dato, el número de
aspirantes al TOPIK ha aumentado casi un 14.000
por ciento entre 1997 y 2019.
En 2019 fueron unos 400.000 aspirantes, casi
cuatro veces más que los que se apuntaron
para los exámenes oficiales de español DELE.
Y no olvidemos que el coreano es un idioma
minoritario a nivel global, con apenas 80
millones de hablantes nativos, con lo cual
es un verdadero hito.)
Y, ojo, porque como apunte hay que decir,
que España se gasta cada año 170 millones
de euros en el Instituto Cervantes - básicamente
en sedes y empleados públicos - cuya función
esencial es promover el español por el mundo.
Pues, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Con los datos en la mano…
La apuesta por la empresa privada y los contenidos
competitivos de Corea del Sur ha tenido mucho
más éxito.
Sobre todo si además tenemos en cuenta que
el español es el segundo idioma con más
hablantes nativos y que es mucho, muchísimo
más importante en el mundo.
Pero no nos desviemos.
El caso es que todo este impacto se traduce,
obviamente, en una gran fuente extra de ingresos
para la economía surcoreana.
Y ni siquiera se trata solo de eso.
También es una forma de promover la imagen
política de Corea en el resto del mundo,
lo que además aumentar los intercambios comerciales,
diplomáticos y políticos, puede ser particularmente
importante en caso de conflicto, por ejemplo,
con Corea del Norte.
Es evidente que las cosas que conocemos y
que valoramos nos importan mucho más.
Es algo que ahora también están persiguiendo
países como Israel.
¿Os habéis dado cuenta de que cada vez hay
más contenido israelí en las plataformas
de streaming?
Pues, ojo, porque sus implicaciones son más
importantes de lo que podríamos pensar.
Fijaos por ejemplo en esta noticia:
(La cuarta temporada de Fauda bate récords
de audiencia en Oriente Próximo.
i24news)
(Fauda, la polémica serie de Netflix encabeza
las listas de audiencia de los países árabes.
The News)
Fauda es una serie centrada en el conflicto
palestino-israelí.
Una serie de producción hebrea que ahora
está contribuyendo a cambiar la imagen de
este conflicto en los países árabes.
Es un altavoz increíblemente importante.
Claro que el uso de la cultura es tan solo
un ejemplo…
Pero no es ni de lejos la única manera de
conseguir objetivos similares..
Hay otras posibles estrategias que pueden
convertir a un país recóndito y/o relativamente
pequeño en población o en toda una influyente
potencia a nivel mundial.
¿Queréis saber más ? Pues atentos.
(EL PODER DE LA BILLETERA)
Aparte del cine, las series y la música,
que sin duda son herramientas buenísimas
para mejorar la imagen de un país, lo cierto
es que hay mucha más tela que cortar.
Un ejemplo clarísimo lo tenemos, sin ir más
lejos, con el caso de Qatar.
Y no, tranquilos porque no os vamos a volver
a hablar del mundial de Qatar, aunque lo cierto
es que este evento tuvo mucho que ver con
todo esto que os estamos contando.
Como una enorme campaña de marketing político…
Y económico.
Sin embargo, hay todavía algo más importante
que eso.
Y es que, veréis, como muchos de vosotros
seguro que ya sabéis, Qatar es uno de los
mayores exportadores de hidrocarburos de todo
el mundo.
Está especializado s obre todo en la exportación
de gas natural licuado, lo que lo ha convertido
en uno de los países más ricos del planeta.
Qatar tiene dinero a raudales…
¿Y sabéis qué?
Hay una forma de utilizar ese enorme dinero
para no solo obtener rentabilidad…
Sino también influencia.
Este emirato del golfo pérsico invierte buena
parte de los beneficios de la explotación
de hidrocarburos a través de un fondo soberano
llamado Qatar Investment Authority.
(Este fondo cuenta con más de 450.000 millones
de dólares en activos, lo que supone más
de 150.000 dólares por residente y más de
1 millón por cada persona con nacionalidad
qatarí.
Pues bien, el grueso de todo ese dinero, unos
400.000 millones están invertido en 80 países
diferentes, siendo Reino Unido con unos 40.000
millones el que más inversiones catarsis
tiene.
Por ejemplo, los cataríes poseen unos 12.000
millones de dólares en propiedades inmobiliarias
en todo el país.
Además este fondo es también el mayor propietario
de inmuebles en Londres, al tiempo que también
tiene importantes inversiones en ladrillo
en ciudades como París o Washington D.C.)
Lo cierto es que la lista podría extenderse
hasta el infinito.
Y por supuesto, no solo hablamos de edificios.
Hablamos sobre todo de apuestas estratégicas:
Por ejemplo, las garras de Qatar también
llegan al terreno de las infraestructuras
críticas.
El país ha estado comprando total o parcialmente
puertos y terminales de gas natural licuado
en el resto del mundo.
Y también tiene participaciones en un montón
de multinacionales.
Sin ir más lejos son uno de los mayores accionistas
del Grupo Volkswagen.
Evidentemente el control de estas infraestructuras
y su peso en el accionariado de muchas grandes
empresas le da al gobierno qatarí una enorme
influencia en todo el mundo.
Pero, un momento, porque ahí no termina todo.
El dinero qatarí tiene también otros usos
más “alternativos”.
Por eso de buscar la influencia política
y social, han hecho fuertes inversiones en
el mundo del deporte.
Sin ir más lejos, y seguro que todos lo sabéis,
Qatar es b dueño del París Saint Germain.
Es su buque insignia.
Asimismo, la principal cadena de televisión
del mundo árabe, Al Jazeera, también es
catari.
Es decir, que Qatar está aprovechando el
dinero del petróleo y del gas para buscar
no solo rentabilidad sino también influencia
política y económica.
Controlar enormes medios de comunicación,
grandes clubes de fútbol, infraestructuras
críticas y grandes paquetes de acciones en
algunas de las multinacionales más importantes
del mundo, hace que los qataríes siempre
sean recibidos por la puerta grande a pesar
de ser un país de apenas 2,7 millones de
habitantes, de los cuales poco más de 300
mil son nacionales.
Es un uso muy particular del dinero para lograr
no solo rentabilidad sino también poder blando…
Doha se ha convertido en una de las grandes
capitales políticas del mundo árabe y la
chequera ha jugado un papel clave.
Sin ir más lejos, el dinero qatarí ha servido
también para impulsar su hermanamiento con
Turquía.
Y sí, es verdad que Qatar también ha desarrollado
muchas acciones de corte estrictamente político,
como por ejemplo el apoyo a los hermanos musulmanes;
o de corte militar, como regalarle a los Estados
Unidos la mayor base militar de este país
en Oriente Medio, pero lo cierto es que la
chequera ha jugado un papel clave en que Doha
sea mucho más importante e influyente que,
por ejemplo, Kuwait, un país mucho más rico.
Digamos que aprovechar los recursos disponibles
para ganar influencia es otra de las claves
del poder blando.
Os puede parecer de cajón, pero lo cierto
es que no es algo tan habitual.
Pero, antes de finalizar este vídeo, no podemos
dejar pasar una tercera vía que los países
relativamente pequeños tienen a su alcance
para convertirse en grandes potencias políticas
además del uso de la cultura y del dinero.
¿Sabéis a qué nos estamos refiriendo?
Pues..
Atentos.
T3 (REYES DE CORAZONES)
Otra de las formas de rivalizar con las potencias
más poderosas del mundo es hacerte abanderado
de causas justas, y proyectos políticos.
Para hablaros de esto os vamos a poner dos
ejemplos súper dispares: Canadá y Cuba.
Hablamos de dos países quee juegan en esferas
geopolíticas totalmente diferentes, pero
que han sabido explotar sus puntos fuertes
para conseguir bastante relevancia a nivel
regional, e incluso internacional.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es…
¿cómo?
Pues fijaos, en el caso de Canadá lo que
hicieron fue convertirse en un abanderado
de las libertades civiles y la protección
del medio ambiente.
Por ejemplo, Canadá ha sido uno de los paí
ses que más en serio se ha tomado la declaración
de la ONU para los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando…
todo esto suena precioso pero, ¿realmente
se puede conseguir influencia internacional
con estas cosas?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
Esta puede ser una de las herramientas claves
para conseguirla y Canadá es un claro ejemplo
de ello.
(Este p aís norteamericano ha sido uno de
los grandes impulsores de importantes tratados
internacionales.
Por ejemplo está el Tratado de Ottawa, firmado
en 1997 que busca la prohibición de minas
antipersonas.
O el Protocolo de Montreal de 1987, que fija
las pautas para la reducción del uso de los
clorofluorocarbonos y así poder proteger
la capa de ozono.)
Y puede que a algunos todo esto os parezca
poca cosa, pero todo esto contribuye a crear
marca país e incrementar su influencia internacional.
Pensadlo así, todo el mundo quiere estar
cerca del más popular de la clase.
Y esto es algo que afecta a gobiernos, empresas,
inversiones, productos y profesionales.
Es en cierta forma el marketing de toda la
vida aplicado a países.
Pero…
¿qué hay de Cuba?
¿Por qué hemos metido a un país tan pobre
en este vídeo si encima se trata de una dictadura
comunista?
Pues bien, aunque parezca contradictorio,
precisamente van por ahí los tiros.
Un país tan pobre como Cuba, que no tiene
ni dinero, ni empresas importantes, ni un
ejército moderno, ni prácticamente nada
de nada, ha logrado convertirse en uno de
los países más influyentes de btoda América.
¿Cómo lo ha conseguido?
Pues recurriendo a las estrategias políticas.
En un pasado vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik
vimos como utilizaban a los médicos.
Ese sería un ejemplo.
Pero Cuba va mucho más allá, y si destaca
por algo ha sido precisamente por hacer un
uso intenso de la estrategia populista que
podríamos resumir en: “los países subyugados
versus Estados Unidos y Europa que son grandes
potencias imperialistas y explotadoras.”
Este discurso se ha comprado y mucho en muchos
países latinoamericanos como en Venezuela,
donde los cubanos primero consiguieron instaurar
una dictadura fantoche a través de Hugo Chávez.
Y después, con el propio dinero venezolano
del petróleo, lograron financiar su particular
revolución por el resto de América Latina..
La idea parece brillante…
Quizás malvada pero brillante.
(Cuba ha promovido por todo el continente
partidos políticos, grupos de presión social
e,incluso, foros institucionales como el conocido
Foro de Sao Paulo.
Espacios de dónde surgieron políticos como
Rafael Correa,, Evo Morales, Daniel Ortega
o Manuel Celaya.
La idea sobre la cual se construyó la influencia
cubana en América Latina fue bastante pragmática.
El régimen castrista se dio cuenta de que
la izquierda no tendría éxito en Latinoamérica
si no se desprendía -al menos de cara a la
galería- de los viejos dogmas.
Dogmas como por ejemplo acabar con la propiedad
privada o establecer dictaduras proletarias.)
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿todo esto para
qué?
¿Más allá de la cuestión puramente ideológica,
qué interés podría tener Cuba en exportar
su revolución?
Pues bien, para mucho s analistas su objetivo
primordial sería precisamente garantizar
la propia existencia del régimen cubano.
Con la desaparición de la Unión Soviética
a principios de los 90 y la grave crisis económica
y social que este hecho causó en el país
caribeño, los Castro se dieron cuenta de
que necesitaban una red de apoyo internacional.
Una red que tenía que estar en América Latina,
países cercanos, que hablan el mismo idioma
y que tienen más o menos la misma cultura.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Salió bien, y noticias como esta son tan
solo una prueba de como un país pequeño,
atrasado y pobre logró una enorme influencia
internacional.
N3(El 50% de la gasolina que produce Venezuela
se envía a Cuba, afirma un líder sindical
de ese país
'A la población le llega únicamente el 10%
de la gasolina que se está produciendo'.
- Diario de Cuba)
En fin, ya lo veis, hay muchas maneras de
conseguir influencia internacional pese a
ser un país relativamente pequeño.
Desde los contenidos culturales de Corea a
la política revolucionaria de Cuba, pasando
por las macro inversiones económicas de Qatar
o la filantropía de Canadá.
Lo que está claro es que si se consigue desarrollar
algo de creatividad con una buena visión
global, prácticamente cualquier país puede
convertirse en una gran potencia en influencia
geopolítica.
Y no lo dudéis, todos los países que hemos
visto en este vídeo han cosechado grandes
beneficios con este tipo de estrategias.
Así que poca broma.
Pero ahora, llegados a este punto es turno
para ti: ¿crees que tú país podría tomar
como ejemplo a alguno de estos países para
tener más presencia a nivel internacional?
¿Crees que este tipo de poder de atracción
es duradero en el tiempo?
Déjanos tu comentario aquí abajo.
Y recuerda, si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” podréis disfrutar de un 83% de
descuento y 3 meses gratis de Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.